[Music]
the rich roll
podcast hey everybody welcome back for
another
amazing episode of roll on i got an
awesome show coming up for you guys but
first
you know what really sucks what really
sucks
is going out for a run only to start
chafing on the inner thigh or when
you're in the gym
and you're distracted by how
uncomfortable your clothes are
is this familiar to you guys i hate that
it's terrible
it's so hard to find that perfect pair
of
workout shorts or running shorts why is
that well
look no further folks let me tell you
about ten thousand
the highest quality best fitting most
comfortable affordable
no bs training shorts i've ever worn
these guys keep it simple with three
premium shorts built for all the ways
you train
one for versatility in every workout one
built for durability for your toughest
sessions
and one designed to be super lightweight
and fade away while you train
not to mention you get customizable
liners and inseam options as well
basically you can just completely
customize the perfect short for you
my favorite is their session short with
a five inch inseam it's become my go-to
for
basically every workout whether i'm
running doing yoga hiking
with a family it's super lightweight
it's got an insanely comfortable liner
and it includes
a permanent anti-odor treatment i just
love
everything about ten thousand it's just
no bs
great products check out their killer
shorts and the over thirty five hundred
five star reviews to find your new
favorite pair every org is free shipping
free exchanges and free returns so go to
ten thousand dot
cc and use the promo code rich roll at
checkout for
twenty percent off your first order
that's ten thousand
dot cc you spell it out t e n t h
o t-h-o-u-s-a-n-d dot c-c not dot com
and use promo code rich roll for twenty
percent off that's ten thousand
dot cc promo code rich roll
we're also brought to you today by birch
living so
it's like a bazillion degrees here in
the santa monica mountains
and last night going to sleep it was
still like 90
out and as somebody who's perpetually
tossing
and turning and hot in the night i
really can't imagine sleeping on
anything other than
my beautiful birch mattress which keeps
me insanely cool
surprisingly cool and comfortable all
night long here's the deal
birch mattresses are all natural they're
made with organic cotton made in the u.s
along with sustainable american steel
springs
my mattress that i keep in my tent has
this awesome pad that goes on top of it
which makes it super comfy
it's basically a very high-end product
that checks all the boxes
made affordable by cutting out the
middleman on top of that
one percent of every mattress purchase
is donated to the national forest
foundation and birch purchases
carbon offsets for each mattress sold
they got tons of certifications in the
industry for their safety
and environmental sustainability too
many to name right now
just know that this is a purchase that
is good for you
and good for your conscience the birch
mattress comes with an industry-leading
25-year warranty
it ships straight to your door
completely free and you get to try it
out for a hundred
nights risk free if you don't love it
they'll pick it up and give you a full
refund and right now
birch is offering 200 off all mattress
orders for my listeners
just go to
dot birchbirchliving.com slash ritual
for two hundred dollars off your
mattress order
that's birchliving.com rich roll for 200
off your mattress order all right me and
my hype man adam skolnick are back
today we talk about a ton of stuff
beirut
what is happening with the post office a
challenge
that we offer to rid our lives of
single-use plastics and many many other
subjects
including listener questions on
journaling and creativity
navigating a breakup tools for
self-discovery
and the growing trend of city center
exodus so strap in because it's time to
take
roll call
hey everybody we're back welcome to
another edition of
roll on i kind of feel like we should
call this roll call
roll call yeah i don't know maybe we
need to rebrand it i'm not sure
either way i'm here with my hype man
adam skolnik journalist
author swimrun aficionado
environmentalist
activist hey good to be here roll call
wait we've had this is like the sixth
one so should we just rename it every
six
give it a new name for every single
every episode every six pack i don't
know
let us know what you guys think uh quick
overview on the format
uh which is a little bit different than
my typical long-form interviews
we generally touch on a big story
we have a few thoughts on a couple
things today we share a teachable moment
we do a little
show and tell and we do listener
questions
do i miss anything you missed the part
where we got
uh evicted from the usual studio because
of a construction crew
so today we are in the third iteration
of our makeshift studio adventure
we're on this like tour of trying to
find a different place to record the
podcast
for seemingly every episode so just to
backtrack when
kovitz started we decided the
responsible thing was to move the
podcast out of my home which is where
i've done it
for many many years and we found this
amazing space
this beautiful huge cavernous studio
location
that was ideal for not just audio
recording but for
video we had this beautiful long table
we created this set
that space became unavailable so we
moved to a smaller room and tried to
recreate the same
look and feel and today we showed up in
that location to discover that there was
a construction crew camped out front
unloading
a gigantic industrial drill out front
and preparing to drill literally feet
away from the microphones and we
realized okay this is not going to be a
tenable
recording situation so at the last
minute we scrambled found a little room
to record i'm
on a bit of a tight timeline today so we
were unable to get the video
equipment up and running so today is is
audio only
and i should also point out i don't know
if i've
mentioned this on the podcast yet but we
are closing on a permanent
studio space a headquarters for the show
for the long term and that's very
exciting
worldwide headquarters that's amazing
worldwide rrp headquarters
is underway and that means
more of what you love yeah it'll
probably be thanksgiving by the time
we're fully in but we've closed on the
space it's a
raw brand new 2000 square foot i think
warehouse space so we're going to build
a set
we're going to build offices it's going
to be like the ultimate hang
and i'm super excited about it we're
also gonna document it
on video i got my man davey here and
we're gonna do a little
series on um the construction
of that and the intention behind it
which i'm pretty excited about as well
so stay tuned for more on that
that's gonna be awesome the word on the
street adam is that
uh you've decided to tackle the zone two
aerobic training how's that going
we have we should call this section
fitness corner or something like that
fitness in the gray zone fitness
check-in after our conversation the
other week
yes thank you for that by the way i i
went out as soon as we had that
conversation
i ordered a garmin tri
chesty which i've named chester chester
the heart rate structure chester the
heart rate
flogger and so i wear that now
and right away i went out with it and
i did a benchmark run in the desert this
is right before the heat wave to try to
set your zones
you said the zones well i read that math
stuff right
yeah that you sent over and then you
also sent the warning prepare to be
humbled
and so straight away like my first runs
were like as you said
10 and a half minute mile kind of pace
keeps me in that
132. so according to math because i
haven't done the lactate training 132
based on my age
is my target right which is not a highly
accurate number i should yeah because
you gave yourself a range right like
yeah it's not a black or white thing
it's a range it's a spectrum
and the diy method of trying to
establish your zones based on your age
is an okay way of doing it but
ideally you want to get into a proper
lactate test where they're
basically putting you on a treadmill or
putting you on a stationary bike and
ramping up the speed or the watts and
then
pricking your finger for blood at
intervals as you notch up the intensity
and that way they can determine with
great specificity
what exactly your zones are yeah and i
will do that
um as soon as the pandemic is over right
whenever that may be at the meantime
so i figured based on what you had said
you said your range is like 130 to 143
so i gave myself a range basically i'm
trying to stay in the green
zone on garmin which translates to zone
two um
on strava and everything else so what i
found is i can
it's not hard to run in that zone like
it's it's not supposed to be right and
and so i'm like well i could run at that
zone kind of forever like
that's the good part but the bad part is
once i left the desert and came back to
my normal swim run
terrain i'm just seeing everybody pass
me and it's
slower than 10 and a half minutes a mile
yeah it's like
in some cases it's 11 and a half minutes
a mile it's so slow
it's hard for me to run at that pace and
so um
and so i'm kind of giving myself a
little bit of of
slack but yesterday i did a seven and a
half
mile swim run workout uh which typically
takes me
maybe an hour and a half i guess and it
took me almost
like over two hours and i just felt a
little bit demoralized i felt like
you know but it's only been a couple of
weeks so i'm just gonna stick with it
i've i have talked to
teddy and uh ted mcdonald and a couple
other people
and it sounds like to really get
better into so that your zone two
becomes an eight and a half minute mile
instead of a ten and a half minute mile
or or slower that you also have to work
in some
tempo runs like you were saying and some
intervals is that what you'd say
yeah but that's less important than just
persistently training
in that zone two really should like once
or twice a week
have a speed or tempo workout
okay but you don't need to be doing
those that often the focus the graviment
of the training needs to be in that zone
two
space and it is humbling yeah but that's
again
that's the discipline that's the work
it's checking the ego
yeah and staying consistent with it and
the other thing i would add to that is
what you will find when you're not well
trained
in your aerobic zone the minute you
step it up and go to a tempo pace your
heart rate will spike drastically
and then when you drop back down into a
zone 2
cadence it will take a long time for
your heart rate to come back down and
the more fit you are
the more aerobically fit i mean
by virtue of training in that zone 2
space
the more quickly your heart rate will
come back down like you'll be able to
normalize
so you'll be able to like ramp it up
like okay i'll do an interval
a 60-second tempo run and then bring it
back to zone two
and your heart rate will come right back
now wow and that's a great
indicator of how fit you are if when
you're trying to come back down you're
super winded and it's taking a long time
for you to
normalize once again that's good
information
that you have work to do so really it's
just because that's what i came
home yesterday finding it so hard to
believe like so if i just keep doing
because what i did yesterday was what i
normally do three mile run plus
mile swim plus three mile run plus kind
of thing and that's seven and a half
miles it tends to be and so i'm thinking
like
so if i just keep doing that zone two
pretty soon those three mile runs are
gonna get fast
like just from that yeah but you have to
be extremely patient
this is a long game like six months this
is not
the uh the menu for the time-crunched
athlete
this is the menu for long-term success
like years right but if you invest
six nine months persistently training
this way
you're gonna see tremendous dividends
i'm excited because
running has always been really hard for
me it's always been and that's made it
less fun like it's always been
uh suffering like even if i'm running
nine and a half minute miles it never
feels easy
and running this way does feel easy
um which i like and if i can get faster
than i was before
and it feels easy like that's a to me
that's a huge carrot
i love that there was quite a bit of
feedback
from the last time that we talked about
this and a lot of people were saying oh
i'm trying this for the first time
and what's great about it is that
it's fun because you're not exhausting
yourself if you finish a zone two run
and you feel super tired or spent you
didn't do it right you're not supposed
to be
spent at the end of these and that is
counter programming because we feel like
when we train or we work out
we should you know give it our best and
then it and when it's all said and done
we can be like oh man i really laid it
all out there
this is the opposite of that right and
again that's the discipline it's a
different kind of discipline it's a
withholding discipline but it's still
you still burn a number of calories it's
not like your calorie counts that bad
right um i'm just worried that someone's
gonna call like i was getting cheered on
by people because i was running so slow
they probably thought that like
something was wrong with me
yeah and i just don't want anyone to
call the paramedics on me right
like i've had people call lifeguards and
fire people on me like in hawaii when
they saw me
way out swimming and they're like he
doesn't seem like he's going fast enough
to mean to be out there
you know like they thought they were
saving my life and then i'd i'd come in
i'd swim in and i
i hear sirens i'm like god i wonder what
happened to somebody
i hope they're okay and then i get to
the beach
the fireman's like wait a second were
you way out there and i'm like
uh yeah yeah that was me and he goes
you're okay and i'm like yeah
i did something right yeah someone
called someone called
search and rescue on uh-huh yeah they're
just not used to seeing people that far
out
i went and swam in malibu the other day
and i went way past out the break and
and it occurs to me i'm like they're
probably watching me
worried you know like i'm fine but you
know that's their job
yeah i know it's fun it's fine i'm like
i just don't want to get charged for
search and rescue
if i didn't need it and just to put it
into perspective when i was training for
my first ultraman in 2008 and i was
trying to acclimate to this program and
and fighting it all the way
thinking this is a terrible idea like
how am i ever going to finish this crazy
race if this is
the protocol and i remember getting
passed
by like pregnant women pushing their
babies and stuff pushing just
teacher baby and real baby i'm training
for this ultra endurance race and i
can't you know
i can't even keep pace with you know so
just you know invest in it believe in it
trust in it i do i trust you and the
cool part is i've been getting quicker
anyway doing this gray zone thing and
you know for me though like running a
10k at 6.5 miles
an hour pace takes a lot of energy like
i can't imagine doing that for two three
hours but i can't imagine doing this
you know green zone like zone two
running at five and a half miles an hour
for two or three hours like the others i
can see myself yeah
and you'll be able to do that the thing
that you'll then have to bear in mind is
this understanding that your heart and
your lungs will develop more rapidly
than
the ligaments and the tendons in your
joints right in your legs
and so there'll be this inclination this
desire
to ramp up your volume quickly because
you feel so good and you do have that
sense like oh i could do this all day
and you're like
it's saturday i am going to go all day
but the problem is
it takes time for the muscles in your
legs and the joints and the tendons and
the ligaments to acclimate to that load
and you have to be very careful and this
is a big reason why
a lot of people get injured because they
you know allow themselves to ramp up
that volume too quickly so
again it's a matter of like building the
volume
very very slowly even when you want to
go harder and further
holding back putting in a bigger week
putting in another bigger week then
having a rest week where you really dial
it back and then notching it up very
very gradually and for a long time
it feels like you're not doing anything
right and you're like when am i going to
train
right right right but the curve is like
asymmetric like it feels flat for a very
long time and then
when you get to a certain level of
fitness and acclimation
then you can dial up the volume and
that's where you really start to
realize the benefits of this and see the
gains i love it did you just call me
asthmatic
i i called you yes that's your new i
like that that's your new uh that's a
word i've never heard before nickname
for the podcast
i will say that um i've gone in the
other direction
now for a little more counter
programming yeah they say
in the sacred secret halls of recovery
that you can't transmit something you
haven't got
and part of the mentorship relationship
that you have in that community
is that um you gotta walk the walk like
you can't tell people
or advise people to do a certain thing
if you're not doing it yourself
and part of that dynamic when you're the
person in the mentorship role
is that it holds you accountable like it
forces you to be
honest and look at yourself in the
mirror in a deeper way
and so after i delivered that monologue
about all this fitness stuff the other
week i thought
am i doing this myself for the most part
i am but i thought you know i could do
better like saying that publicly is
holding myself
to a higher level of accountability and
i've made this decision to do something
i haven't done for a very long time for
years and years and years for the last
decade
i would say that my training has been 90
percent
zone 2 aerobic with like 10
speed and strength and i've decided
because i'm sort of in a rut with all of
this and i'm having some
back issues that i've talked about and
because i've been just
repeatedly like running and running and
putting in all these miles for so long
that i need to do something different
for my long-term
functional strength so i'm flipping the
equation completely and i'm doing
90 percent strength and 10
aerobic which is something i haven't
done since i think i was like
40. so it's been like 13 years so
strength meaning
uh high heart everything from no well
mostly right now and i only started this
two weeks ago
but mostly functional strength
and weight training okay like back in
the gym yeah yeah yeah like just
trying to get my body strong like
building it up
like this is my foundational work to
take a body that
is very efficient and acclimated to long
distance pursuits and
running and trail running and things
like that and to get really really
strong oh wow so it's going to be
a gun show come november it's going to
be like that's like
goggins body yeah i'm kind of doing a
little bit more
well i mean with less of the endurance
stuff right now like i'm really going to
back off
the running and the cycling i'm still
going to put in some
you know runs and some bikes and some
swims but
the focus is really going to be on not
bulking up but just getting
really solid and strong because i want
to heal my back
as i get older you can carry that
endurance machine forward you always
have that and i can always tap back into
that
yeah but what you lose is the strength
and i don't want to lose that strength
and i've noticed that i have lost a lot
of that and i want to build that back
and
on top of that i also want to show that
a 53 year old
guy who's been vegan for 13 years can
still pack on some heat yeah
in the upper body yeah department
interesting
um so that's kind of what i'm so the
home gym is all decked out or is that
going to be over
i have i have a little bit of home gym
stuff and then there's a gym
near my house that is open
for limited times with social distancing
so i started to explore that like if
you know i'm using that safely for
limited amounts of time throughout the
week
so i'll see how that goes that's
exciting so the goal is like when the
book comes out in november
yeah it's it's gonna just be a massive
gun show
you're just gonna are you gonna sign
your own biceps for people
no see and now i'm on the hook right
i got to follow through now yeah now you
now you've declared it
right no but i think that's cool you
know i think that speaks to beginner's
mind and the power of just trying
something new and switching things up
yeah like you're doing with this yeah
yeah i don't want to be stale like i
want to do something different and keep
this whole
like journey dynamic i love it all right
so
what's the big story well the big story
is beirut it is
so the synopsis as we all know we've all
seen the footage
a huge cache of ammonium nitrate a
chemical used in fertilizer but also
explosives including the oklahoma city
federal building attack
was detonated at the port and it was
many many times bigger
than what was used in that attack in
oklahoma city it killed 150 people plus
injured 6 000 left hundreds of thousands
of people homeless many are still
missing
critical infrastructure like hospitals
in the country's main port were
destroyed
uh nearly half the city was damaged and
that was kind of like the last straw
politically and socially
for what's been happening in lebanon and
beirut before the coronavirus
pandemic even the economy was shrinking
in lebanon the currency crashed because
the banks there
were kind of caught out in a ponzi
scheme like
interest game where they would the way
they were getting foreign investment
into the country was promising a high
interest rate
and so foreign investment was coming in
but in order to pay that high interest
rate they had to
keep getting more investors right and so
then investors started
macro bernie madoff situation like a
macro level
exactly on a national level and sometime
late last year the foreign investment
stopped coming because people sniffed it
out and they're like wait we can't do
that this isn't going to work and then
at that point it became hard to get your
own money out of the bank if you're
lebanese and
the currency crashed and so people lost
their you know half their net worth
or more kind of overnight in the blink
of an eye and so then this happened
right so now you have to try to repair
stuff
and there's a pandemic and there's a
pandemic and so
like what's gonna happen how much is
steel and glass gonna cost can you get
your own money out of the bank so this
is kind of the totality
of what's been happening in beirut which
is a lot i mean can you imagine
if all of a sudden on top of everything
we've been dealing with in the united
states if all of a sudden you couldn't
get your money out of your bank
and layer that on top of just a history
of embattlement that this
you know historic place has weathered
over the millennia
yeah it seems to always be this vortex
of
conflict and strife and beauty and
like and this incredible you know
cultural
kind of oasis yeah um so yeah and and so
and what have
the people in beirut been doing since
then there's been protests sure but
they're also
the armies of volunteers are the people
cleaning up that city um business people
have been the ones
investing in crews to help clean up
there's
first aid stations and food stations
being set up entirely by volunteers
entirely by the citizenry
and the government has quit and there's
no real public
response to this it's all been kind of
private groups organized but
in a community level this is what
happens when you have no government to
help you
right you have no agencies to help you
you know and you
you love beirut yeah i mean personally
on a personal level it's
it's absolutely heartbreaking i mean we
all saw the videos
of the explosion going off and you know
it i've never seen anything like that i
mean it was just
so horrific yeah i can't imagine that
shockwave was just
nuts there was one video that was taken
from
somebody sitting at an outdoor cafe that
i've been to
and the whole thing gets blown over i
mean i've been to
i've been to beirut twice and i love
that city and i've gotten to
know quite a few people there who i
consider to be my friends the first time
i went for a speaking gig
it was many years ago it was probably
2013 maybe
maybe 2014 and i got to meet with a
bunch of
beirut business leaders and i gave a
talk and
they like wined and dined me and
introduced me to all these people and
took me all over the place and gave me a
tour and they just were so
incredibly welcoming um
one of the people i met on that first
trip was
a legendary endurance athlete called
maxime chaya who's kind of like their
national you know adventure athlete
sports hero he's just
amazingly dynamic accomplished
dude he's climbed everest i think he did
the seven summits okay he's done all
kinds of he he's like the iron man
athlete in beirut
because this is not something that a lot
of people are doing no um
and i think he was even like the
cannondale bicycle rep
okay he was the one responsible for
getting people on bikes in beirut and
all kinds of amazing things that this
guy has done over the course of his life
and he took me to his home which is
outside beirut
in the hills maybe like 45 minutes
outside of town
and we went cycling through uh the
countryside
and you know through this mountainous
range it was just cypress
you know groves it was just so
incredible what year was that
i think it must have been 2014 2013 i
can't remember
and one of the people that i met also on
that trip was a woman
called may al khalil and
she founded the beirut marathon she's
got this incredible back story that she
tells in a ted talk
i made a video about that experience
it's on my youtube channel and also i
shared it on instagram recently yeah i
saw that she was an avid runner
this is a place in the world where
there's not like running isn't part of
the culture necessarily
but there is a small running culture
there she was part of that she got hit
by a car
in a near fatal accident was told she
would never run again but she wanted to
give this gift of running to her people
and she created
this marathon that quickly became the
biggest
marathon in the middle east and she
invited me to
come and participate so in 2015 i went
back in november
to participate in that marathon and it
was a life
changing experience for me to
run in a part of the world that's so
foreign to our
western lens and what i
experienced was people from all parts of
the world and all parts of the middle
east
people that typically are at odds with
each other for
reasons political and religious
convening
collectively for this shared celebration
of peace where everybody just runs and i
was very moved by the experience like
women running in burqas and
women coming from you know like saudi
arabia where it's not okay for women to
run
coming and running and seeing that
really
gave me this beautiful sense of the
power of
humanity and shared experiences well i
mean beirut being
where it is it's like it was occupied by
the romans and maybe even
some people say the egyptians before
that well there's roman ruins
right all across the city like the the
remnants of these roman baths and the
foundations of these roman buildings
and it's layered like the rings of a
tree like it just depends on how
far down you want to dig and you just
tap into culture after culture after
culture there's mosques there's
cathedrals it's this
intersection of all these different
cultures and
i was told when i was there like if you
want to build a building
like every everything is a historic site
so it's like well if you build here
you're building on top of this
they have to do this calculus of like
yeah it's a roman ruin but like
there's no place where you're not going
to be affecting
some aspect of the past the middle east
is like that it's just so old and
there's so much history there
it's like uh yeah so the romans and then
it was the ottoman empire for centuries
and then after world war one i believe
it was a french protectorate
and then independence in 1943 and since
then it's been fraught you know there's
palestinian refugees there the syrians
and israelis were kind of fighting
over territory and then uh there was a
civil war in civil war in the mid 70s
yeah and um hezbollah which is an
organization that's funded by
iran has an occupied part of the city
that
kind of belongs to them kind of their
own thing and they had us they squared
off with the government not too long ago
so it's
it's this it's complicated it's
complicated and there's christianity as
well as
it's not just a muslim city it's it's
it's really multicultural
and uh you know armenian presence there
as well
it's incredibly beautiful also and we've
all heard you know the adage that
it is or it was the paris of the middle
east yeah it's certainly true and they
have this beautiful esplanade along the
the water where you know i would go
running every day and
jump into the sea and it's it's quite
spectacular but
it's also seen better days you know like
when i was there the first time
there was something going on with the
government where the trash wasn't
getting picked up any i mean it's just a
[ __ ] show
right you know literally from a civic
perspective and i had conversations with
some of these business people like
you know these are very sophisticated
well-to-do people
and i said you know if you ever thought
about leaving like you could go
be a banker in new york city or
something like that but they just love
beirut they believe in lebanon and
they're there for
the sake of you know basically trying to
improve
this impossible situation that they're
in i have a colleague from
a lonely planet who has been basing
there and
um i checked in with him afterwards and
how he's doing and
and he's like you know one of the things
he said was we don't have air
conditioning right now
which i guess doesn't matter because we
don't have windows right and he's still
living in the place without windows
like because some people just don't have
the money or the places to go
so you know some buildings have been
condemned but if your building hasn't
been condemned
and you have no windows you're kind of
like at the mercy of
when those get replaced the blast radius
of this thing was so
extraordinary too because i was watching
videos of journalists on the ground
in neighborhoods that i know that are
quite distant from
where the bomb went off yeah and i
couldn't believe the devastation like
literally
you know miles away from where it
exploded
it's just it's hard to wrap your head
around it well you were there
and then when you ran the marathon you
left and like two nights later there was
like an actual terrorist right and i
tell that story in that video that i
made but basically
the marathon was november 8th
i left on the 10th and on the 12th
isis bombed one of the hezbollah
neighborhoods called
borge el raj barajnae i don't know how
to pronounce that
but it's right next to the airport and i
you know i'd driven through that area
and i'd walked
neighborhoods quite close to that like
the day before i left
and i just remember leaving
lebanon was such a full heart for its
people and its history and such a deep
appreciation
and a sense of empathy and then to see
that happen
was so shocking and devastating it was
the number one
news story in the world for a day but
the following day was the paris bombings
which were admittedly much more severe
in terms of
death toll and injuries and the one that
where they're not the charlie had the
night going out all over the city yeah
exactly yeah
exactly that was literally a day later
and that erased
beirut from the news cycle completely
and a lot of people
i think have now forgotten that beirut
had been bombed a day before
yeah because all the focus went to paris
and i think part of that
is this sense that oh it's the middle
east like
bad [ __ ] just happens there yeah and i
think we're seeing a little bit of that
now because we're what 10 days
or so since yeah the blast in beirut
and i haven't seen very much in the news
no about what's happening
you might not see anything unless
something cataclysmic happens you might
not
something else right well the news cycle
is advancing so quickly now that
you know it's it's kind of part of our
news culture i suppose that we just move
on so quickly
that's part of it part of it i think is
kind of this
long held kind of american naval gazing
like here in the united states we don't
really there are always reporters out in
the world reporting on stuff from all
over the world but
you know we don't always get that oxygen
it doesn't really flow there
right unless something huge happens
that's part of it part of it is this
idea of american exceptionalism like
what happens here is the most important
so it kind of
blots out some of this other major
stories so that means that it's on to us
to if you care about the world you know
it's not just what happens here that
matters it's what happens elsewhere that
matters too
and so just to keep that in mind and
seek out those stories
i mean we really have to i know you you
make a point of seeking out
uh stories not just from here but from
everywhere yeah i mean i would add to
that
that you know the first time that i went
there they put me up in this
hotel called the phoenician the
phoenicia yeah which is this incredibly
lavish
hotel that was built during that paris
of the middle east era
and you know it's like this is where
frank sinatra stayed and this is when it
was like really hip to like go to beirut
and they had this incredible nightlife
and all this sort of thing
uh then the civil it was built i don't
know when it was built probably in the
early 70s
and right behind it is the holiday inn
which is a huge tower that was built in
and was intended during its construction
and its first year of operation
to be like the i mean you know when we
think of holiday and we think of kind of
low rent hotels but this was meant to be
like state of the art like this is where
everyone's going to stay
it's going to be unbelievable in 75 when
the civil war began
that hotel became a war zone and just
got
shellacked and it was sort of a symbolic
goal
in this strife like who could control
this landmark
yeah and today it stands as
this gutted bullet-riddled
historical edifice that is like almost
like a symbol like a reminder
of what had happened there like they
could have just torn it down or rebuilt
it but it stands there
just like it looked probably in 1975
after it just got devastated
and it's still a military zone that's
controlled by the lebanese army so when
you go and you look at the top you'll
see
dudes you know like there's military
vehicles in the
you could see them on some of the floors
and then on the on the roof you'll see
guys patrolling with rifles and it's
just a reminder
that this is an unstable region i guess
so to speak and when you tour the city
you'll see buildings all over the place
that are riddled with bullets
or here's a little memorial where a car
bomb went off and so and so died
and there's this palpable sense that
anything can happen
at any time and when you come home it
gives you a greater appreciation for
government stability on some level
although we're seeing a level of
instability now that i think is
leading us to question that but i think
the overarching theme
that i was trying to convey in that
video and what that experience
taught me and my other experiences i've
been all over the middle east i've been
to
multiple cities in saudi arabia i've
been to bahrain i've been to some
pretty amazing places is that travel
breeds
empathy and to the extent that you know
when this pandemic lifts if you're able
to travel
and experience other cultures i can't
stress enough how
important that is in terms of how you
form your world view
and how you think about your
participation
as a global citizen on the planet
absolutely and that's partly why i pay
attention to news from other parts of
the world is because of
i travel and where i did before
the pandemic and you did yeah i was
i would like the asthmatic planet
not exactly um i think we should round
it out
there was a video that you shared with
me about dr isra
sabiani right a chronologist uh based in
detroit who's lebanese who's out there
to get married right you're gonna post
that yeah i mean
i'm sure a lot of people saw this video
went viral the new york times
covered it as did many other
publications but
it was a video of this beautiful woman
in her in her bridal gown
being videoed by a wedding videographer
with a gimbal it's all super pro and
gorgeous and in the middle of the shot
the explosion occurs and you see the
chaos erupt
and in the wake of that everyone was
like who is this woman right yeah it
turns out
that she's a lebanese doctor who is
doing her residency in detroit
and chronology and had returned to
beirut to get married
and i'd read that after that clip
ended she went and started trying to
help people
in her bridal gown like trying to save
people like being a doctor
in the midst of like the calamity which
i think is
really extraordinary and you're going to
post the that bloomberg video which i
think is excellent too that one week
oh there's a bloomberg put out a video
one week later yeah that's the only kind
of
postscript that i've seen like okay
what's going on now
like it's a week later there's what are
the 300 000 people that are homeless now
yeah you know all these buildings are
uninhabitable and high rises yeah right
so anyway so there's things you can do
uh there are charities that and we're
going to post that
right in the show notes this is to give
money to help
in terms of feeding people and health
care and whatever else
contribute to the rebuilding there are
some reputable charities that uh
we're going gonna post right you can
pitch in
cool let's take a quick break we're
gonna
take care of a little housekeeping and
we'll be right back with
more roll on slash
roll call roll call all right hold tight
we got a lot more coming but first
the question i get asked most frequently
rich
what are the best ways to take care of
my health
well going plant-based and cleaning up
bad habits comes top of mind
one of the absolute best things you can
do is to read
to acquire new knowledge learning and
growing from
the experience of other people but rich
it's so hard to find the time to sit
down
and read and learn more well there's an
incredible app that solves this problem
and it's called
blinkist blinkist takes the best key
takeaways the need to know
information from thousands of
non-fiction books and condenses them
down into just
15 minutes that you can read or listen
to
personally my memory isn't super awesome
so one of my favorite aspects of
blinkist is to revisit books from the
past
i also like to glean lessons from books
i don't have time to read right now
but want to down the line one example of
the former
is i read tim ferriss's four hour work
week book years and years ago
i refer back to it from time to time
because there's so many powerful
lessons baked into that text but
i'm not going to go back and re-read
that entire book but i do want to keep
fresh in my memory some of the powerful
tools that he talks about so
during a recent commute to the grocery
store i pulled up blinkist
i listened to four hour work week on
that app basically a 15 minute
synopsis which boils down all the
pertinent points into
a very digestible format and it was
incredibly helpful
here's the deal with blinkist you get
unlimited access to read or listen to a
massive library of condensed
non-fiction books all the books you want
and all for one low price
right now for a limited time blinkist
has a special offer
just for my audience go to blinkist.com
rich roll
try it for free for seven days and save
off your new subscription that's
blinkist spelled b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t
blankets dot com rich roll to start your
free
7-day trial and you'll also save 25 off
but only when you sign up at
blinkist.com
rich roll and finally we're brought to
you today by my friends at daily harvest
when it's blazing hot it was literally
over 110 degrees here
yesterday my desire and general
motivation to cook anything
just goes out the window so i would like
to personally thank
daily harvest refreshing smoothies and
delicious scoops
their new plant-based ice cream from
keeping me from melting
into oblivion this summer daily harvest
is a lifesaver they help you stock your
home with clean delicious food that's
made from real fruits and vegetables
their farm frozen to lock in peak
nutrients and taste
and with daily harvest there's tons of
options for any time of the day from
smoothies to harvest bowls
flatbreads and more and the best part
everything is ready to enjoy
in minutes right now i'm crushing on
their chia bowls
they have this all organic blackberry
and magique bowl i think that's how you
say it it's got blackberries banana chia
hemp seed coconut
and blue magic which is a spirulina
extract it's just
insane but i'm telling you guys their
scoops are where it's at
they're free of additives preservatives
and fillers
and instead made with whole nourishing
organic
plant-based ingredients like black
sesame coconut cream
and even dragon fruit they have four
amazing flavors but the vanilla
with salted swirled black sesame is
my personal favorite it's unreal it's
basically
a plant-based ice cream cone with
ashwagandha
coconut maple cacao it's absolutely
unbelievable so keep it simple this
summer with daily harvest
go to dailyharvest.com and enter promo
code rich roll
to get 25 off your first box that's
promo code richroll
for 25 off your first box at
dailyharvest.com
that's dailyharvest.com promo code
rich roll okay back to the show
[Music]
and we're back adam what is going on
with the post office the teachable
moment
save the post office um okay real quick
the postmaster general
louis de joy a trump donor reportedly
with stakes and competitors the us
postal service has been
heavy-handed in his attempts he claims
to
make it run more efficiently but those
adjustments that he has been trying to
make include the removal of male sorting
machines
at least 19 have been removed from
various depots
each machine can process 35 000 pieces
of mail per hour
so 19 is a big reduction and he's slated
to have 671
more taken out this was reported widely
over the last few days
he's also moved to end overtime pay
which is very critical
because that's how carriers cover for
one another when they are sick
especially now that's a big deal
um so if overtime goes away that means
people
will not get their mail which is also
happening right now so this
these moves kind of underscore this
rising concern across the country
of the integrity of the november
election how is the post office going to
be able to handle
80 million ballots cast by americans it
could be more than that could be less
but that's kind of the
that's the estimation but then there's
also problems that have nothing to do
with the joy which is that
mail carriers aren't showing up for work
maybe because of the pandemic either
they're scared of it or they could be
sick
i talked to my own postal carrier
admittedly that's just anecdotal
evidence but what he was saying is in
santa monica 21 carriers didn't show up
on saturday
and when those carriers don't show up
residents don't receive their mail
some people haven't received their mail
for a week at a time wow
and he's taking on he's working 60 hours
a week he's taking on overtime if
overtime goes away
he won't work 60 hours a week right so
he's not going to cover for it
you know so that this is a problem given
the election is happening
and it's a problem in general you know
like functional societies have
have impartial postal services that are
not driven by
crazy yeah that the post office is being
politicized in this way
it's like you don't even you just take
it so for granted you never think twice
about whether your mail's gonna come
until now right so apparently the post
office needs 25 billion dollars this is
according to trump
to be adequately funded through not just
the election but through the holidays
pelosi just called the past
representatives back into session to
deal with this so they definitely going
to do that
there yeah that's happening there's a
vote supposedly scheduled for saturday
to fund the post office of course then
it has to be also passed by the senate
and signed by the president
on sunday mark meadows the white house
chief of staff did express
openness to funding the post office
through the election
so we'll see about that but yeah i mean
you know
is this a power grab it certainly smells
that way
you know first of all how a postmaster
general is a partisan employee is crazy
but what's happening there does seem to
be in line with what happened at the epa
whereas a republican president is in
power and he's appointing people who
undermine that agency that they're
supposed to be overseeing and
implementing
policy so it's troubling for those of us
who care about
the environment the epa or just having a
post office you know but what do you
think about all of this well i think it
certainly
smells of an authoritarian weaponization
of what should be and is a public
utility
for a partisan gain and
you know whether or not that is the case
it will function
to produce that kind of result unless
it's resolved yep
and i think you know i've sort of
watched how twitter has exploded over
this and the outrage and all of that
and it it goes back to what can we
control like we can talk about this and
be outraged and voice our concerns on
social media
and you know all of that but
fundamentally
all we can do is control our own
behaviors what is our responsibility
well
regardless of your political perspective
we all need to vote
right so let's take care of that in
advance the election is in november
you can vote by mail now take care of it
now don't wait
until there's some kind of crazy
crunch yeah i haven't i don't think i've
gotten my ballot yet but
one solution i just got it you just got
ours did you just get it yeah yeah we
just did
so i think that you can vote now and
that will ease the mind because
there is this fear that even if you post
mark before the election and if they
don't get it
by a certain time it won't get counted i
also
i'm a big proponent of early voting you
know there's less polling places for
early voting but there's a number of
them at least in california that starts
29 days before the election
and you can go in and it's very quick
you don't wait in line nobody's there
really
and you go in with your kind of sample
ballot prepared so it doesn't take that
long
and you can wear a mask and it can be
safe and you can wash your hands
afterwards and
that's available to everybody in 39
states
there is some sort of early voting
sometimes it's two weeks sometimes it's
10 days sometimes it's a month like in
california
sometimes it's the thursday before the
election but it's still an opportunity
to do it in a way that you don't even
have to worry about the mail
so there's things you can do i think
also having conversations
about this with people you could call
the white house and urge them to fund
the post office this is not
should not be a partisan issue yeah you
know having a postal service
that functions is a positive thing for
people
yeah of course right do we have a
verdict on whether
there's gonna be pull stations open on
election day or is that
still being debated right now no i mean
so far election days have happened you
know
there's been primaries held everywhere
so and we're going to get into a little
bit more
a little later in the win of the week
about kind of polling stations and
opportunities to
add to what's already going to be
administered by
election commissions but um yes the
problem with some of the primaries has
been
less polling stations than usual but not
no polling stations
so that's something worth watching you
know like the amount of polling stations
that's something worth watching so
that's why early voting and voting by
mail very early
are two solutions you can control to
make sure your vote gets counted and the
fact that we're even having this
conversation
is [ __ ] mentally i know what is the
fraud vulnerability with mail in voting
you know it's a good question i don't
think there's been any proof that
there's
fraud i guess one idea if you have two
addresses you could potentially be
registered in two
places and vote twice i guess but i
don't think that that has
held water because if those get
discovered then two votes don't count so
i don't think there's been any proof
there's certainly no
irrefutable proof that more mail-in
voting
equates with more voter fraud voter
fraud is not a big
issue in the united states right we're
led to believe that it is
you know what the biggest voter fraud in
the history of the united states has
always been
is voter suppression yeah that's the
voter fraud the electoral college
allows you know minimizes states like
california's impact on the election as
well
but the biggest voter fraud has been
voter suppression in florida
and gerrymandering and gerrymandering
yeah but for presidential election
gerrymandering doesn't matter
but in florida you know there's been
this uh some states and have long had
laws on the books
permitting ex-felons from voting
florida's
state government changed that i think
what is either
either no there was a referendum and
they basically allowed felons to vote
for the first time and then the state
government enacted a new law
basically saying yeah they can vote as
long as they paid all their fines that
they had
unpaid fines which is kind of like this
pull tax which used to be a trick
used to eliminate poor people and black
people from being able to vote mostly
black people voting so there's a
movement a foot we'll talk about in win
of the week about how to deal with that
so there's there's solutions the
solutions are
vote by mail vote early and there's
petitions uh save the u.s postal service
petition asking for the removal of
louis le joy and the full funding of the
post office and that's out there so
we'll link that up in the show now the
concern
from my perspective come november is
that
in the event that a significant portion
of
voting is done via mail that that's
going to delay
the result tabulation and it just
creates this cloud of uncertainty that
will make it easier for somebody to say
there's there's something not right with
this or to stay in office and not
leave like short of a landslide in
either direction
my concern is the instability of
the government in terms of having a
clear
like directive for who's going to be the
next president yeah
like if trump loses but he loses by a
margin is the guy going to leave
is this going to be a thing that we're
going to have to deal with i mean he's
already
you know ceding this idea that it's a
fraudulent landscape
right which creates the foundation for
an argument that you know something is
amiss i agree it's problematic i mean
why can't we
figure out how to have safe encrypted
online voting
we trust our money online right our
phones have facial recognition
there are encryption experts working on
voting um
it tends to be extremely complicated i
think travis county texas was looking at
trying to
include encrypted voting that's
different than the voting machines that
we have which are not connected to the
internet
except when they're being programmed and
then they are connected to the internet
i think what we're seeing with hacking
if the machines themselves are connected
to the internet
they are vulnerable so you they
shouldn't be connected to the internet
they can be networked and encrypted
and there are some very smart people
looking at that but it has to be
kind of a faraday box situation exactly
it's not online
exactly so if it's not online then you
still have to go to like a polling
station
you still have to go to a polling
station now there are other last time i
voted
in the midterms it was like a digital
kiosk thing
right so the digital kiosks those are
digital voting machines but
they are not connected to the internet
except when they're programmed
originally and then when they're
standing in the polling place they are
not supposed to be connected to the
internet
but encrypted voting the same thing they
wouldn't necessarily be connected to the
internet but the idea is even if they
were
they'd be unhackable because a vote
creates a digital footprint that is then
encrypted in the way that it can only be
unlocked
in a very certain way and even if you
hack into it you won't know what that
vote means because it'll have a digital
code
right and so you won't be able to tell
what that vote means so you couldn't
necessarily
monkey with the results i feel like the
word blockchain
needs to be heard here i know nothing
about blockchain other than that
it means a distributed network where
nobody can control it
right but perhaps there's a solution in
the blockchain that could resolve
this kind of digital voting situation
all right let's move on all right so you
posted something on instagram that like
was amazing this week and it was all
about kind of your journey in sobriety
but in a very specific way and
in what happened in oregon in the rehab
center and i just thought it was really
poignant so i just wanted to
find out what motivated you to do that
and kind of where you're coming from
with that
why i appreciate that adam thank you
feels like i told you to say that
i know but you didn't though yeah i
i think you know the idea behind that
post
was really to just honor some of the
people that have been
teachers for me over the years and we
tend to think of mentors and teachers as
these
highly qualified aspirational
individuals like oh i want
gary vee or warren buffett to be my
investor mentor
or david goggins to be my fitness mentor
but the truth is
we're all surrounded by teachers all the
time every human being has a story to
tell they can be instructive and helpful
in your life and i think i said
something like the prophets walk among
us
like i said you know i spent all this
time with a bunch of you know hopeless
you know marginally criminal drunks and
meth heads and crackheads and needle
fiends and junkies but i became very
bonded to these people and i learned a
lot
where was this exciting time or not
exactly it's a treatment center in
oregon and just you know being in
in the recovery community for you know
many many years at this point you know
over 20 years
met a lot of people and people from all
walks of life who
collectively get together in a way that
you know these people would ordinarily
never meet
right and when you open yourself up and
you're
available to what they have to say and
you're present
i think most people are would be amazed
at what you can learn
from you know the people that are in
your immediate
environment if you just slow down and
and pay attention and i think
right now in this pandemic we're being
compelled to slow down like the fast
pace of our life that we've acclimated
ourselves towards has been interrupted
and with that means we're having fewer
interpersonal interactions the the
number of people
that we're exposing ourselves to every
single day is far limited as truncated
but
there's also an opportunity for the
experiences that we are having with
those
fewer people to be more meaningful and
to the extent that we can make ourselves
more
available to them that we can be present
and listen
i think that there's you know lots of
wisdom to be mined from that
yeah i mean that's what stuck with me is
like to be humble enough to know that
like
you don't have all the answers and
anybody can teach you something any
interaction can teach you something even
if it's something even if that
interaction is
i know i don't want to be like that or i
see where that person
has made this mistake and what it's done
to their life
and that's helpful to me but there's
also this you can't be defensive
you have to be open right like a
defensive posture
closes off all those possibilities
doesn't it sure
but if somebody's sharing their
experience again it goes back to
this idea of breeding empathy right like
if you can connect with another human
being and look for the similarities in
their experience and how you can relate
to them
interpersonally that brings you closer
to that individual
it amplifies your own inherent ability
to be
empathetic and i think that's very
healing and i think we need that right
now we're so divided and we're so
acrimonious everybody is on this razor's
edge right now there's so much tension
in the air it's being fueled by economic
insecurity and
the pandemic and this fear of getting
sick and the vitriol on social media and
everybody's just waiting to snap
yeah they're not listening they're not
present
they're not experiencing other people
for who they are they're just waiting
for their turn
to reply yeah to the extent that we can
let go of that
and just remind ourselves to be present
and available to another human being's
experience
our own lives are benefited in the
process of that
i love it cool what are you doing now
show and tell
although you can't see it um i am
wearing
a hat that has the words net positiva
on it this is a hat made by a company
called breo
they are an environmental company
founded by three surfers
ben neppers kevin ahern and dave stover
they met in sydney australia they had
different jobs at the time that were
trying to figure out a way to
channel their passion into the ocean
because they're surfers
and the environment in general and a way
to to do it in a business-oriented way
and not as a non-profit and they ended
up
getting funded to start a
fishing net recycling business in chile
at the time the sardine fisheries and
in chile which tend to feed the salmon
farming down there
the people that would go out and harvest
the fish with their nets
when the nets got ripped up or it was
time to get rid of them they would just
dump them
because there was no stay in the ocean
they would just stay in the ocean ghost
netting which is just like one of the
most destructive ways of dealing and
plus they can break down and
you know they're made out of nylon so
it's a plastic these fish get caught up
in them too fish
marine mammals and then obviously
contributing to the plastic problem
so these guys went down and they created
recycling centers
and incentivized the local fishermen to
bring their nets back with them
dump them there and little by little
they devised a way
to turn those nets back into plastic
nerdles which is the base element little
pellets which are the base element for
all plastic products
and so they take that plastic net return
it back into the base element
and then theoretically they can be
turned into anything so they've done
that before they came out with
skateboards and frisbees
and then they started working with
patagonia and the brim in this hat
is 100 made from these nets from
fisheries that were used in chile and
argentina
all of the patagonia hats which is
patagonia's number one
selling item they all now have hat brims
made out of the berea plastic and a lot
of their technical gear and waterproof
gear going forward it's going to be made
from this kind of post-consumer plastic
product which kudos to patagonia for
that
kudos for these guys to build a business
model that actually
works and is profitable they have grown
they have greg swenton runs their
marketing team who sent me this hat
which is the hat that they give to the
fishermen okay so that's
it so this is like makes them more
mindful
when they're out there like if they're
wearing that hat they're going to be
thinking about it yeah because their
product's called net plus
netpositiva in spanish and so they have
they're working with fisheries all
across chile now in argentina
they're looking to start working in peru
they're really growing really
expanding in the ideas that can be
turned into any sort of high value
plastic product
and it's different you know some people
why can't we just recycle the plastic
that isn't drifting in the ocean and
turn it into something well that's
because that's such degraded material
it's not a high level material you can
turn that into you think there are like
plastic bottles floating out there but
it's like a
goopy gel right yeah you can make it
into a bracelet or something like that
but the idea is to make that into a
high-tech
climbing you know apparel you can't
really do that but you can with this
stuff because it's a high-level
high-quality post-consumer recycled
product
so are they just taking the nets when
the fishermen
are ready to retire them or are they
actually going out and retrieving
no the nets that are already out there
the fishermen now are
completely educated and informed and
they bring the nets back and they put
them in
into you know basically receiving
centers which are then taken to
warehouses that
bereo has and they're boiled down into
new plastic that's cool yeah that's
super cool
and providing jobs in chile what's the
uh website for that
i think it's berea.com but i will make
sure it's on the show
notes yeah um on a similar note on the
issue of plastic
i had darren olean on the podcast
recently that episode hasn't gone up yet
and we kind of concluded it
with me asking him like what's the most
impactful
thing that a person could do yeah
something like that and he was like well
you got to get off the single-use
plastics yeah right like of course like
that's something that we all have
control over like the water bottle
emergency is just completely out of
control
and to the extent that we can eradicate
single-use plastic from
our lives like that's a very tangible
practical
doable thing that each and every citizen
individual can take control over in
their lives
and i've been thinking about that ever
since we talked about it not that it's a
new idea
i've thought about this in the past and
i thought you know what
i'm gonna really take this to heart and
try to do this
and i found myself at the store the
other day i just finished a workout
i needed some water and i'm like okay
i'm not buying water in a plastic bottle
that's for sure
i ended up buying water in a glass
bottle and then i remembered
oh julie told me to pick up some ice
because our ice maker is broken in our
fridge
so i just grabbed the ice and i checked
out and i was feeling all good about
myself that i bought this glass
bottle and then i realized all this ice
is wrapped in plastic
like even when i thought i was paying
attention yeah i realized that i was
not paying attention at all and so i've
decided to embark upon
a 30-day single-use plastic moratorium
to see if i can do it
and what i've realized is you know to
that point
it's harder than you think that's hard
because it's so endemic to
every consumer product that you come
across even if you're buying something
that
is made out of something else there's
still a plastic wrapper on it or if you
buy something online and it gets
delivered it's there's
plastic is everywhere and it's more
challenging than
it's not just let's start with no more
plastic water bottles but
beyond that it gets complicated really
quickly it does and
and especially now in the pandemic i do
our food shopping at the farmer's market
i bring my own bags and you're good
you're my you're my role model and try
not to
take the plastic but during the pandemic
like for the first time even the
farmer's market stuff was
pre-packaged and i was happy to take a
plastic bag and you know i was
we talked about this when i was
originally on your podcast in 2016. you
know i'm a five gyres ambassador
working on marine plastic issues and i
care a lot about it because there's
billions of
plastic particles in the ocean they tend
to look like plankton to
marine life they get nibbled it ends up
toxifying our food chain
um get fishing line wrapped around the
necks of turtles and sea lions i mean
it just it you could take an arctic ice
core and
pull it out and it's got plastic in it
you know like we are the plastic age
300 million tons of a year of new
plastic is being turned out
there's new plastic plants being planned
because
you know oil prices are down and there's
all this over you know there's too much
fuel to in too much petrochemical now
because of fracking and so that's going
to go into these plastic plants they're
trying to up it to 600 million
so there is a corporate cycle
at work to keep single-use plastic in
our lives right
but you can minimize it and uh when you
do minimize it
there's all sorts of ramifications that
are positive for you
and for uh the world so yes i mean it is
something that you can
get rid of uh very easily if you try and
that's
really just as simple as i mean i used
to do the same thing i'd buy
plastic water bottle all the time as
soon as i realized what was happening
i just switched to carrying my own water
with me right it's not hard to do
right and that's again that's a very
obvious thing but
it's the you know nefarious little
things that you're less aware of you
can't fully
get rid of it i mean you're going to buy
especially if you're vegan you buy tofu
or
tempeh yeah everything is is wrapped in
it's wrapped in plastic like but how
you can't really get around that 100 of
the time if you're doing food shopping
it's almost impossible like
if you if you're buying tofu like there
is really no option you're gonna have to
buy plastic
it's crazy yeah that there's no other
option but that doesn't mean that you
shouldn't
be vegan because like the meat and the
fish also comes
into the store in plastic so even if
they wrap it for you and paper it was
once
a single-use plastic yeah it's crazy
yeah
so what i wanted to do is make this kind
of a community thing yeah
so what i want to do is embark upon this
30-day
single-use plastic eradication project
which is really aspirational
right like you're not going to be able
to do it 100
right but to the extent that we can
aspire to do better
and do the best that we can i'm going to
do this
i invite everybody to join me and to
chronicle your experience like where is
it impossible
where is it frustrating what are the
changes that you made and i think what
i'm going to do is
i'll post like a image on instagram or
something like that i'll do a post on it
and i've got roka who's a been a sponsor
of the podcast sent me a box of
sunglasses i've got like six pairs of
amazing sunglasses but i already have
like so many i don't need any more
sunglasses so i want to give these away
so i'll post this thing
on instagram and then what i invite
everybody to do
is to embark upon this with me and then
share
your story in the comments on instagram
and then we'll
select some winners and i'll ship off
those sunglasses a select few whoever
has the best story or you know the most
kind of impactful experience the way
that you communicate it we'll just we'll
select a few people
beautiful there are there are people who
are really good at being no waste
kind of i guess well there's some no
waste gurus yeah
so trash is for tossers uh which is
created by lauren
singer right i've tried to get her on
the podcast in the past we had some
scheduling problems okay i've been in
contact with her but she has like a
no-waste
store in brooklyn i think did she open
one in la too they were going to i don't
know i mean i
met her on the five drivers expedition
in the in the north atlantic gyre
and she is like the real deal i think
she started just doing what you're doing
i want to try to do this for a full year
and she was blogging about it or
something and that's how her whole
journey began
yeah and so she can teach you you know
the best way to
i mean she makes it easy now you can buy
like laundry detergent from her that
doesn't come in a plastic bottle
but she she kind of started creating
those solutions on her own
right and she has all sorts of tips so
at trashes for tossers on instagram
that's a good place to go yeah she's
cool there's another woman her name is
b something bea i can't remember her
last name
if memory serves me of french descent
and she lives in marin
she's got you know she's got a couple
kids she's also written a book about
this
and she's i think she did a ted talk i
saw her speak once
and her entire garbage for the year
for an entire year of living with her
husband and two kids
was all in one mason jar i was like how
is that possible
when i look at the amount of refuse that
our family
produces weekly and i just think that is
so aspirational and badass it is it's
amazing it also
looks like a huge amount of work but
it's kind of like when you're not vegan
and you look at it
you're like oh that's got to be so much
work you must spend all your time
dealing with that right
it just becomes second nature i'm sure
for her and for
lauren like this is just their lifestyle
like they they're so acclimated to
these habits that it doesn't seem
onerous to them anymore
no it's kind of like i i would guess
like you know how when
you first start eating almost or vegan
exclusively or
in my case like 99 how like all of a
sudden your taste buds change
so that when you do try something that's
not vegan it tastes kind of dead to you
the flavor's not there but vegetables
and fruits have much more flavor i mean
that was my experience of it
i imagine there's side effects like that
from doing this too like where you start
to see these
these hidden bonuses that you didn't
anticipate right and suddenly
everything pops out to you and
technicolor we're so used to it we don't
notice it you know
if you have to backtrack it probably
hurts yeah
so i think this 30-day challenge is
equal parts you know environmental yeah
and also
mindfulness like it's like how aware and
present are you
with what you're doing and the choices
that you're making and again it goes
back to slowing down like if you slow
down
you enhance your awareness your present
what you're doing and when your hand is
reaching out
to the shelf to pick something up like
to really consider
what that is whether you decide to buy
it or not
i think is a interesting and
compelling practice to adopt beautiful
nice one should we move to win of the
week let's do it
um the big win of the week i'm going to
give to lebron james and patrick mahomes
you know who they are the best
basketball football players
alive they are come together along with
other elite athletes professional
athletes to tackle voter suppression
and one thing that they're doing is
opening up polling locations
in dormant stadiums like dodger stadium
in los angeles is going to be a polling
place
there's arenas all over the country that
they're turning into polling places
they're also aggregating their funds and
paying poll taxes in florida
to make sure maximum number of black
voters can vote
they're basically attacking voter
suppression of black people
across the country in a handful of ways
and they've created this organization
called more than a vote
and we're going to link to the letter
that they just put out to fans kind of
an open letter
to detailing the work they're going to
do i just think
that is going to have a major major
impact on voter turnout
which is going to be one of the big
variables
to this election in november and
regardless of which way you're leaning
which they say in the letter
it's your right to vote and it's really
your responsibility to vote but if
you're not allowed to vote
then that complicates things or if
access to voting is just too onerous
because of the pandemic that is that is
voter suppression so
that's super badass yeah very cool the
other big win of the week
the other big win of the week we say
this
tongue-in-cheek but it is a win is uh
the new
georgia republican congresswoman named
marjorie taylor greene
she won on a campaign supporting q anon
so is she the winner of the week or is q
and on the winner of the week
i think you and i think takes the cake
for the weekly
keeps winning which is not big winning
they keep winning it's unbelievable
i mean we've talked about q anon before
on the show but i think it is worth
exploring further like we kind of mock
it and dismiss it
and we think of it as this bizarro
fringe
movement yeah but it's easy to malign it
but that's only because they think
like this cabal of people are trying to
kidnap babies and eat
drink their blood like tom hanks of
course right
it's a global elite of evil child
molesters
right and drinking the blood of children
right the drinking the blood part i mean
that's how that's tom hanks's secret
yeah yeah i don't know where to begin
with this
but let's start with the fact that this
fringe
ideology in in certain ways the argument
can be made that it's gone
somewhat mainstream it's kind of reached
this weird
cult religion fever pitch
and i think it poses a legitimate threat
to
our democratic institution clearly i
mean i think kevin roose who
um we talked about with rabbit hole
basically he's an incredible reporter
incredible reporter and i think he was
like the idea is that president trump is
the secret hero and he's going to
destroy this cabal and as president he's
the big hero
but kevin roose i think he pointed out
that like or no someone else did like
that at one point
q anon was is thought of as fringe now
but so was the tea party i don't know if
that came from kevin or not
but he didn't know he wrote an article
basically you know questioning whether q
anon was the new tea party right that's
it that's right
so so he he wrote that piece and you
know that's scary
mm-hmm but it's and the thesis of it
there's a lot of distinctions there's a
lot of reasons why q anon is very
different from the tea party but
the parallel that he's trying to
establish is that there's this sense
that
these things are fringe movements that
we don't need to pay attention to
and is he's basically saying like this
is a lot bigger than people think like
we mock it and we malign it and we
dismiss it
but on facebook there are groups with
millions of people
who are chiming in and paying attention
like what's the next q drop and how are
we going to
decipher this coded language and what
does it mean and
it's almost like this
adult immersive
video game experience that's filling
a gap in people's lives now that we're
working from home and have
extra free time and we're feeling
less than great about our daily
existence like it's
it's something it's a it is an
incredibly immersive
role-playing game and it's giving people
who perhaps are lacking some level of
purpose and meaning in their lives
something to do something to participate
in
to be a community member you know with
other people
to you know throw these ideas around and
it's metastasized into this political
movement that is actually
really frightening it's kind of like a
cult pop cultural meets politics
movement
like it really is it's like it's like
the anti-v
for vendetta it's like the opposite of a
view for vendetta type movement like
but it's the same sensibility this like
this idea that we're butting up against
the machine
and in trying to really kind of un you
know on this
theme of empathy like trying to
understand like what is going on with
somebody that
compels them so much about this movement
and i think it's like this perfect storm
of economic instability
fear about the pandemic and the fact
that in so many ways
the government has been dishonest with
us
and has let so many people down and
there's a distrust
of systems and with that there's space
to develop these
conspiracy theories so when we hear you
know the narrative shifting
and we become suspect of trusted
institutions
we're seeding this landscape for this
kind of thing to occur so
you know the fact that it even exists is
baffling to me
but i guess i can understand it on that
level and then when we
are dealing with ideas around the virus
too
like i think that's really just
amplified
the intensity yeah insecurity is a big
part of it i think um
like empathy is one reason to discuss it
i think like there
might be some of your listeners might
have knee-jerk reaction to this is like
why do these guys keep talking about
these kinds of things why is it why are
we getting political
why are we having these kinds of
discussions and and beating the q anon
uh drone so loudly um and part of that
might be because a lot of us
who listen to you and care about these
issues we have tools
for ourselves that we can we could drown
out the world we might have tools we
might have
the ability and wherewithal to be able
to block it out and our lives might be
just fine if we just train and meditate
and
eat well and our lives are going to be
good but like there is something about
cluing into these larger trends that
does matter right like to even people
who
might have it wired on an individual
level on a family level and none of us
have it wired completely i mean the
acknowledgement of that but we
we have tools why does it matter to keep
talking about these things to you
that's a great question how do i answer
this i mean i think that
it matters because truth matters
and i get concerned about our ability
to function as a healthy society when we
have this breakdown in communication and
when we're living in
various distinct realities like if we
don't
share a sense of what is actually going
on then how can we move forward
collectively
yes we can focus on our individual
well-being we can develop our
spiritual life and our emotional lives
and improve our relationships with those
that we're surrounded by
but when you scale that up how are we
functioning collectively as a society
and i see
in the same way that we have an epidemic
of lifestyle disease i'm seeing a
disease
of the mind right like what is the real
virus right now is it coronavirus or is
it
an infection of ideas
that is driving people apart from each
other
and as a result breaking down
our ability to cohabitate in a healthy
way
well said i've been i just finished a
little light reading it's
plague by albert camus and um
because i've been reading plague and
watching plague movies um
during this period of time but one thing
that comes out of it you know it takes
place in the 1940s in north africa
there's a blue bomb plague outbreak
and it's told from the perspective of
several characters but the thesis
is people are more good than bad and so
even though we
are harping on some of these things i
think it's important for us to affirm
that that is
that we do believe that and that's one
reason for me i think it's good to talk
about these things because
you know the only reason we're able to
or not the only reason one of the main
reasons we're able to build these kind
of
lives that we choose and follow our
passions and work out and meditate and
do all the things that make us whole
is because we have a system that works
you know that we feel like this
underlying that's the
whole idea of the black lives matter
movement that there's all sorts of
people in this
in this country that don't have don't
feel stable to be able to build a life
that is holistic because they always
have to be looking over their shoulders
but
if you have an erosion of truth then
we're all going to be
in that position too and that's the
warning of it right that's the warning
shot
so to me it's like we need to build that
so everyone has that foundation of
stability
we can rely on things being equal and
fair and that we can all
have the opportunity to build those
really uplifting lives
yeah well said all right um should we
even get to some listener questions
yeah all right this is from camille in
dekalb illinois
hello this is camille baker from dekalb
illinois
i was listening to one of the recent
roll on segments and i heard
rich mention that he
includes journal entries from
artist's way as part of his morning
mindfulness routine and
as an art therapist i am very intrigued
shall i say richly curious about
how you stumbled upon the
book as part of your journaling process
and
what your connection to creative
expression
is as part of your gosh i say your
wholeness journey
or your healthy journey or just kind of
your wellness journey is the best way to
say it
um so yeah love your show love you it's
great
thanks bye thanks for your question
camille
journaling is a huge part of my daily
routine my daily regimen i would say
that it's more than just
a part of my wholeness or wellness
journey it's part of being human i think
you know i began
journaling in 1998 initially when i was
in treatment
when i got out of treatment i started
seeing a therapist
and he suggested that i check out the
artist's way
and i started doing the program there
and
i've done the program many many times
over the years but
one of the things that i've maintained
and continued to do with
great consistency are the morning pages
and the artist date which are two of the
fundamental practices
in the artist's way the morning pages
for those that don't know
are this practice where you start every
day by writing out three pages in
longhand in a notebook not typing on a
laptop or a computer but actually
getting pen and paper
out and the idea is to not edit yourself
to just start
channeling and writing whatever is
coming to mind
the idea being you're kind of clearing
the cobwebs you're trying to connect
with your unconscious
and opening over time
that channel of creativity to surface
and i found it to be
one of the most powerful and practical
things that i do to connect with my
creativity and by
creativity i mean not just creativity in
a limited
sense of like oh i'm gonna be a writer
or a photographer or a filmmaker or a
stand-up comic i'm talking about
the innate creativity that is endemic to
all human beings and part and parcel of
what it means to be a fully
expressed human being creative
expression is entwined
with everything that makes us who we are
we're all
creative beings and i think that most
people are walking around
incredibly creatively suppressed
or stymied and i think part of our job
as people who are here trying to grow
and progress is to bring voice to our
unique sensibilities that's what we're
here to do that's what we're born to do
i go into depth about this subject with
chase jarvis on the podcast so you might
want to check out that episode
he's a photographer and a filmmaker he
wrote an incredible book about
creativity
and his whole thesis is you know as
human beings we're all born
creative and then we over time
through our educational process that
creativity gets drummed out of us and
then we start to think that creativity
is the purview of a select group of
supremely talented people that we can't
relate to
and that's just a lie you know that
creative expression is in
all of us in our own unique various
forms and
bringing expression to that figuring out
what that is
and then sharing it with the world
is a gift that we're all capable of
doing and i think it's incumbent upon
all of us to
to do that to bring more expression to
that you might also want to listen to
podcasts that i did with brian koppelman
who's a screenwriter
he's the creator of the tv show billions
he wrote the movie rounders he's written
a lot of movies and he's just incredibly
prolifically creative
person and this is a guy who's been
doing
the morning pages for like decades and
he never
misses a day and he swears by it he's
like
i will not skip that no matter what and
he attributes
his extreme creative output to the
diligence of this daily practice and i
think there's a lot of profundity in
that
so check it out get on that
artist's way program get those morning
pages cranking out
yeah i mean it's like the danger is you
just become a consumer only right like
we're creators too
so like we don't want to just become
consumers
and you know it goes back to what we
were just talking about with
role-playing like susceptibility to
role-playing type games or like a
purpose that's beyond you
you're just a consumer in that
relationship and it's so easy now to
only consume yeah it's in our pocket
just be consuming
from that digital device in our pockets
all day long
and it takes diligence to carve out
time for creativity so every time i look
at my phone i think am i using this to
create or am i using this to consume we
talked about that
yeah in a previous episode absolutely
cool
let's hear from san juan puerto rico
hey adam hey rich gabriel all the way
from
san juan puerto rico rich i discovered
you
through my youtube feed and since then
i've been watching countless videos of
you
and wow has it been so beneficial to me
personally and
my overall well-being and i thank you so
much now my question is
how do you get over a breakup
now i was in this seven-year
relationship with this person
that i grew up with my first love we
grew up together we saw each other grow
through the bumps but nonetheless we
wanted to get married
to each other and that was the plan for
2020.
now the complicated part of the
relationship was dealing with her
in-laws
and it got to a point where it was just
abuse for me personally and i endured so
much
confusion and hardships that
emotionally i was just derailed there
was one moment that i decided that i
can't take it anymore
and i ended the relationship for
my emotional health and it's not easy
anyway thank you guys so much take care
guys much love
uh thanks for your question gabriel glad
you're getting a lot out of the podcast
i
appreciate the kind words and i feel for
you brother
breakups are rough man first thing i
would say is
you're 25 you're young you have your
whole life ahead of you the fact that
you're even thinking about how to
process this in a healthy way
speaks to how healthy you are as an
individual so i full confidence that
you're going to navigate this
successfully
and look back on it and it's just going
to be a blip on the radar
that's the first thing the second thing
i will say is that
you ended it for your own personal
emotional health
and i think that also speaks to how well
that you're dealing with this it tells
me that
you set a boundary for yourself and held
yourself to that boundary and that's
an indication of self-esteem
and self-respect so good job there
i would add that i don't think that you
should
repress any of the emotions that you're
experiencing
this is the moment to feel all of the
feelings that you're having
don't run away from them try to engage
them each one of those feelings
is an opportunity to learn something
more deeply about yourself and what
makes you tick
and to be patient you can't rush this
process you can't
snap your fingers and just get over
somebody time heals and this is going to
take
time and just allow that process to
unfold as it wants to unfold
rather than trying to control it
i also think that culturally we tend to
look at
breakups as failures this is a
relationship that didn't work out
i feel bad about it because it failed
but
i really don't like that nomenclature or
that perspective i think every
relationship that we have
every relationship has its own unique
timetable
and its own unique shelf life and every
relationship whether it perpetuates
for the course of your lifetime or it
ends a month later
are all growth opportunities and i think
a relationship can be
a success and still reach that
termination point just because
it's ended doesn't mean that either of
you
failed because people are not static
everybody is growing and regressing
and changing all the time and the idea
that two people
who are together are doing that in
lockstep
is bananas of course we're going to grow
at different speeds or we're going to
move in different directions at
different times
maybe one person is growing at a rapid
rate and the other person is regressing
or not growing at the same rate or
with that growth comes a change in your
value systems that
make you suddenly incompatible i mean
that's
normal and i think it's shocking that
any relationship works out
when you think of it in that context you
know you
you begin to understand that most
relationships become
irreconcilable with time and making a
relationship
work is a gigantic undertaking
and sometimes ending them is the right
choice so
the growth for you and the assignment
for you is to really
go deep into these emotions that you're
feeling to really do a forensic analysis
of
what happened to do an inventory of your
part in not just the breakup but in the
relationship itself and what led to the
breakup
and to identify whatever character
defects emerge that you can work
on for yourself and to identify the
growth opportunity like what was
dysfunctional about the relationship and
why and
you know what were you told that you
were doing
that didn't work and can you see that
objectively
and own any truth that you can identify
in that
and then what is it that you can change
so that moving forward you can be in a
healthier relationship with
a more suitable partner in the future
like how can you approach your next
relationship from a healthier
perspective you know we also have this
kind of cultural mandate of looking at
partners as completing us or filling
some need or
you know aligning with some programming
or or inherent
pattern that we've repeated over time
throughout our lives like for example
if you had an emotionally unavailable
dad then
you're gonna seek that out that same
character trait is going to show up
in the partners that you're choosing on
an unconscious level
or the diametric opposite of that so
it's about
understanding that programming that can
help you make a better
more objective choice next time that's
in your best interest
i would also say that it's important to
focus on
not focus on what's the kind of person
that i want to have
in my life like who is that idealized
girlfriend or partner and instead focus
on yourself focus on trying to be
the best person that you can the person
that you would want to be with rather
than trying to find the person who makes
you feel like that person because
you know water is always going to rise
to its own level
so that's my big speech i guess i will
close that with just
offering that the next time you're
engaging in
a relationship try to approach it from a
perspective of what can i give
to this relationship rather than what am
i going to get out of this for myself
i think the more of that kind of mindset
that you can have then you're in a
healthier
position to have a highly functional
relationship
and you're [ __ ] 25 dude you're gonna
be fine
yeah the only thing i'd say that's very
well said um
the only thing i could say from a guy's
been through some breakups
is that including one when i was 25 is
that
a lot of times even though you were the
one that ended this
and you knew it was coming a lot of
times
when men are anticipating a breakup or
the end of relationship they don't
actually feel the feelings
during that kind of slow dissolution
it's like once you've turned the page
all of a sudden it hits you with a ton
of bricks and you realize and you kind
of go into
weird internal panic mode almost whereas
women when relationship is ending they
kind of
anticipate it and they start feeling
those feelings a little earlier and
they're better equipped to move on
quicker
where and that's my experience anyway
and men
it takes a little bit longer and i
wouldn't expect to feel
necessarily even happy day after day
after day until like a year after it
could take a year before you start to
feel like your normal self again
right and that's not necessarily a bad
thing that's just the way it goes and
and so i wouldn't rush that process i
think patients like you said rich
that's key to these kinds of things and
just don't even think about it like a
year
you will wake up a year from now or from
whenever the breakup happened
and you will be finally feeling like
yourself again that's my
that's my prediction you know what i
just watched recently that i think is
probably the best movie
that he should watch right what's that
swingers
yes that's a good one because really
it's a buddy movie about one guy trying
to get over
his breakup with his girlfriend it's
exactly that that's actually
got kind of a profound message in there
absolutely all the insanity of that
movie
and it gave us uh you know gave us
favreau and and vince vaughn
and so on yeah and many other careers
douglas many other careers yeah
so watch swingers watch swingers that's
the best sap
yeah and don't mind the low production
value that's part of it he's 25 he
probably hasn't seen swingers yet
you might not have seen it's hard for me
to imagine that somebody hasn't seen
swingers but
you know what's sad is swingers is
closed now the the the delhi swingers
that was in the
yeah i know yeah well but the the but
that's not the one they were right
so the the here's a interesting aside
so that the actual diner that they're at
in the
throughout the movie is actually the
one-on-one right right right right
and you know who the mayor of the 101
diner is yeah of course i do but you
tell the people
dk dk gold he is
he might always come back to dk he might
be he might be there right now he might
be
all right all right let's go to north
carolina
hey bridge and adam this is josh from
raleigh north carolina
i've heard it said that the universal is
rooted in the particular
as someone who found your podcast years
ago when peeling the onion
of veganism and endurance sports but
stayed for the honest discussions of
sobriety
my question is this if there is a
through line
of sobriety diet and endurance
what is the universal truth that those
particulars
point to thanks so much i look forward
to listening and it's fine to play this
on air
that's such a good question yes i really
love that question thank you josh
i think that the through line is
self-discovery it's personal growth like
whether it's
some kind of diet protocol veganism or
otherwise
whether it's movement
you know there's these are just tools
for
stripping away the layers that separate
you
from a higher version of who you are
like
when i decided to go vegan it didn't
occur to me that i was doing this to
develop a better relationship with
myself
i wasn't consciously aware of that but
when you strip away
the crap that you're eating suddenly
there's an awareness that starts to
percolate up and i'm like
why did i always eat that thing or why
is
culture set up where we're supposed to
do this and not
question this you start asking yourself
questions and i think
there's a grappling with your higher
self that starts to occur
that over time quickens or deepens your
connection with your higher self you
know whether it's veganism or endurance
sports it could be
minimalism like what happens when you
strip away the excess in your life
and you're left with yourself and you
have to be with yourself and you have to
look at yourself in the mirror
and there's no distraction what do you
do then
how terrifying is that when you have to
meet yourself for who you actually
are so again these are things that i've
used like
endurance sports was fundamental in my
journey because
i was spending so much time alone by
myself
out in nature with an elevated heart
rate and no distractions
and i was very confused at the time
about
who i was and what i wanted to do and
how to express myself
and you know who am i fundamentally
right
as cheesy as that sounds and that
process
was like this gauntlet that really
taught me about who i am and what makes
me tick and what my values are
and who i wanted to be so it's not about
veganism
or endurance sports as much as it is
finding some
analogous vehicle that can be that tool
for you because we're here to
be authentic to who we are like it goes
back to the answer i gave to the other
question like
fundamentally we're here to grow we're
here to express our most
authentic self and we in order to do
that we have to
discover our unique blueprint
and figure out what our values are and
then the journey becomes
how do you align those values with your
actions
i love it self-discovery and that that
is so rich
right because that is like and that's
the universal like the particular is
i'm not going to eat this or i'm going
to do this activity today and the
universal is who am
i right who am i why are we here right
exactly but it's micro and macro because
you're like okay who am i
like because the world's always trying
to tell you who you are right like and
part of that is you
you make choices and depending on how
old you are those choices
end up kind of creating an identity for
yourself that you might wake up and be
like wait a second how did i become this
person it's about regaining control
over those reigns right and rather than
allowing your identity
to be dictated to you by a group that
you know you feel more comfortable being
aligned with or whatever marketing
message or television show or music
video or whatever it is
to start shouldering responsibility for
crafting that identity for yourself
but what's interesting is like you're
saying self-discovery come you know you
started out by
i'm gonna try not eating this and eating
this instead it's like for me
i'm gonna try swimming in the ocean
because it's like feels good
but then you don't realize like that
does become like
it's a spiritual odyssey it does become
an odyssey
what happens when i can't you know pick
up that bottle and drink that thing
yeah and understanding like oh
that was stunting my emotional and
spiritual growth i thought i just like
being drunk
right but there's so much more going on
like these little
actions that you know we don't realize
are
so powerful and potent in determining
like who we are and the decisions that
we make about who we want to be
love it all right last question from a
mystery man
i'm not even sure his name's real he's
in an undisclosed look hey guys my name
is john i'm calling from an undisclosed
location that is not in california or
texas
i was wondering what you guys think
about joe rogan live in l.a moving to
texas
do you think there is a mass exodus out
of major metropolitan
areas and people moving to less
populated areas whether they affect some
climate change or less severe
the overall quality of life better have
you guys personally thought about
leaving california
by the way thanks for recommending down
to earth on netflix my wife and i loved
it
thanks a lot bye cool thanks john i will
answer your question if you will tell me
what undisclosed location you're yeah
where do you live john
first things first i'm now i'm obsessed
with figuring out where john is
he's in a silo deep in middle earth
first things first i'm not surprised
about
rogan leaving california for texas i
think texas fits him it makes sense to
me
it seems aligned with his sensibilities
but also
you know his spotify deal is about to
kick in and i think he stands to save
like
16.8 percent in income tax
by moving to texas from california so
from a purely financial perspective
it makes perfect sense absolutely and
you know he's mentioned it on his show a
couple times i mean he's
if he's more centrally located it's easy
to get people from both coasts
it will be interesting to see how it
affects the show because when you're in
like i can't imagine not living in la
or new york just because by virtue of
proximity to
guests and having access to those people
and the pandemic now we're compelled to
do a lot of this zoom stuff
you know i'm hoping that we're going to
get back to you know some ability to do
these in person and i've been able to do
that
occasionally with a mix of zoom stuff
but at some point when it's safe to
congregate again
how is that going to impact the show but
he's just conducting his show the way he
always has with
doing testing on site and stuff like
that but yeah it'll be interesting to
see
but austin is uh austin is not like i
mean it's a cultural kind of
center as well yeah yeah i mean we
thought about moving to austin
years ago yeah when when we were kind of
going through our you know
financial dismantling right and looking
to really downsize like i
thought really seriously about moving to
austin and i love austin i think it's a
fantastic place
i've never been oddly enough oh it's
cool you would love it you would love it
i'm told
um on a broader level first of all i'm
not leaving
i'm here in california to stay but i
have found myself thinking about it
in a way that i hadn't previously like
where would i go
i'm like yeah byron bay sounds pretty
good right now
like getting out of the us completely um
and i think we're starting to see and we
will continue to see
what i think will be a mass exodus from
metropolitan areas you know with this
work from home movement the virtual
workforce explosion most not most i
don't know about most but
a lot of companies are not going to go
back to normal even
in the event of a vaccine and the virus
lifting a lot of these
things are going to remain they're going
to persist
yeah commercial real estate's going to
suffer yeah we're going to we're going
to see this crazy
real estate fallout and what's going to
happen with that who knows
but listen you've contributed to the new
york times if you were a new york times
reporter
living in manhattan or brooklyn right
now doing stories
nobody's going into the new york times
like why would you there's no reason
that you would have to live proximate to
the corporate headquarters
so why would you where you're paying
exorbitant rent when you could live
wherever you want to live
yeah i mean who knows i mean i've heard
that new york rents have already dropped
because so many people have left because
of the pandemic and i just heard that
today
yeah um we haven't seen that drop in los
angeles yet but i think it could be
coming
i'm like you man i think about it all
the time i think about i think about
leaving all the time but i mean
i could never live away from the ocean
now like i know that
and so i'm pretty much locked into high
rent go to
costa rica you go live in costa rica i
can't but now i'm on this podcast twice
a month
it's hard to get here from costa rica
yeah right i know that's like it's
really messing up my game plan if trump
wins
i think what's happening is the pandemic
is just an accelerant
on all of these trends that were in
various stages of nascent infancy
so virtual workforces online education
all these kind of percolating trends are
now just
blossoming in the light of our current
situation
and they're only going to become
entrenched and
exacerbate this exodus when you realize
that
we can decouple place from profession
people are starting to wake up and
realize like oh if i could live wherever
i want
it's not tied to my employment what
would that look like
so i think yeah of course people are
going to flee the places
where we're seeing you know viral
outbreaks and exorbitant rents to live
in a place where you can have the
lifestyle that you want for yourself
i think meanwhile we're going to see
massive changes in
in education we're already seeing it i
think it's going to put
a lot of mid-tier colleges out of
business i think we're going to see the
explosion of
telehealth again this decoupling of
place and the need for proximity
is really going to amplify these
technological trends that are going to
give
people a different lens on how they want
to live
you know why live in manhattan or
silicon valley if you can
work from home and avoid like rent
that's just
bananas what about
we think about togethernbc areas and
commutes and civic spaces
even when we can congregate again in a
healthy way
what is that going to look like but
don't you think it could be because like
we're basically seeing
a re-run of how things like it used to
be
cities city centers were vibrant places
and then all of a sudden in the 70s
the suburban suburbia
everyone left downtown l.a was a
[ __ ]
and like nobody now it's coming back now
it's awesome and then it's going to
leave again like isn't it kind of like
this ebb and flow and human
in the human space yeah yeah but i think
what's not
going to go away is the human need for a
connection yes
you know like people want to be together
and there's something about
city centers that draw people to them
irrespective of their employment that's
why i think there's going to be a
correction eventually it's going to come
back because
in some places like newsrooms there is
an energy of
collaboration that's important i mean
there is something to that
so i think some companies will choose to
come back to the office but maybe
i mean it's not like it used to be the
big benefit is that you could work from
home but now the benefit will be like
you get to come into an office
yeah you get to get away from your
family you know what i mean
it's weird and like i could do what i
suppose i could do what i do
anywhere but like i miss new york do you
i would love to have
i'm like rents are dropping in new york
like i wonder if i could get an
apartment in new york you know like
even though new york is a [ __ ] show
right now like i miss
that immersion in culture
and people you know and i live in i live
in a beautiful place in l.a but it's
relatively remote like i'm not
in i'm not like the vitality and the
energy
of that place is so specific and so yeah
rejuvenating at least in short bursts
for me
so you know i would want to be in that
community irrespective of
my employment well someone will take
those apartments i mean the good thing
about about new york
uh rents dropping is that there's all
sorts of working people that made the
city cool
like way back in the day like that my
hope is that
it will bring the cool people back right
because new york got boring because it's
just too overpriced yeah all the
interest
all the people that made new york
interesting had to leave yeah
we'll see what happens uh i'm not
leaving california
anytime soon not that anyone really
asked me but
that's okay yeah i'm not going anywhere
anytime soon although i do think about
it i do think about it and i think of
australia as well
but that's because i could get a
passport right yeah
yeah i mean california's got problems
right now but
there's a lot of great stuff i'll tell
you where i wouldn't move from
california and that's
to texas i just wouldn't i've never
moved to texas no i don't think i would
i mean i like it i've been there
and it's cool you haven't been to austin
though i haven't been done that's that's
true i don't i
do want to go to austin reserve judgment
until you visit it austin is cool i
i understand why you're like i'm not
moving there but like i can appreciate
austin i love utah though
i would think about utah really i love
utah um
yeah it's like i'm not moving to utah no
it's beautiful it's like it's like the
it's like almost colorado
i know no ocean that's why i won't live
there but yeah yeah
all right let's wrap this up all right
um that's it everybody thank you for
tuning in thanks for your
questions i appreciate it how do you
feel adam do you feel like we did a good
job today
i feel great yeah i mean i always feel
like we did
well but i mean maybe that's just
enthusiastic well maybe
i have over-inflated self-esteem and i
always think i did well
and then i find out later i thought you
did a wonderful job i enjoyed that
thoroughly you could follow adam at adam
skolnik on all the
social places if you want your message
considered to be read and answered on
the show leave us a voicemail at
424-235-4626
uh subscribe to us on apple podcast on
youtube
on spotify hit that notification thing
on youtube except
not for this one because we didn't film
this one yeah in general i suppose
uh check the show notes on the episode
page at richworld.com we'll put links up
to everything that we talked about
including
all of those uh ways that you can get
involved and contribute you can also
submit your question on our facebook
group the ritual podcast facebook group
um i have one more question before you
sign off
we're in a very superhero room right now
um we're in an undisclosed location
underscores locations surrounded by
various uh superheroes and villains yeah
who's your
who's your favorite batman my favorite
bat your favorite batman
you're coming at me with a curveball
here i know well i'm staring at batman
yeah um got to give it up
to uh christian bale for
sheer intensity yeah i got a soft spot
in my heart for michael keaton
oh really yeah i go christian bale
there's a revisionist history around the
michael keaton batman
is there yeah he's being resurfaced as
the greatest batman
is there oh okay so it's not an actual
episode of revisionist history no no no
it's a it's just a kind of a percolating
cultural
because he's the most like he's kind of
merging michael keaton is like a merger
of
of adam rich meets christian bale a
little bit
i don't know blake what do you think i
like adam westman
really adam west adam west just for
sheer satire
and like i watched me too that was still
on when you were a kid
on tv yeah david do you have an opinion
on this
my only opinion is not george clooney
not yeah
there's consensus i know clooney george
clooney
all right all right this is getting
ridiculous we're done
um thanks everybody who helped put on
the show today jason camayolo
and also blake today for audio
engineering production show notes and
interstitial music
blake typically videos the show but we
had a situation today
jessica miranda for graphics we got
davey greenberg on portraits today
georgia whaley for copywriting dk
for advertiser relationships holding
court at the 101
diner as we speak although i think he's
in seattle right now
theme music as always by my boys tyler
trapper and hari
appreciate you guys thanks for tuning in
let us know how you thought
this one went how did it land for you
hit us up on the socials and we'll see
you back here
in a couple days with another episode
you want to take us out
be cool be kind right on right on peace
[Music]
so
you